she's gonna have it i was a caterer the
producer
the director the screenwriter acted in
it and i was the first we didn't have a
first aid
why we'd have the money
if you're end up in the filmmaker and
making films outside of hollywood
that's hard you have to pray on bended
knee
at the church of cinema
but you have these tools that can help
you tell a story
i want to show someone that's a little
weak you shoot them from above when i
show someone as powerful
you shoot them from below well there's a
dynamic that you get
with the movement of camera films about
movement
[Music]
for the writers you know what the [ __ ]
that means yeah it means
paying me my [ __ ] money here's
the thing why this works if you think
about it they're both right
that really makes it dramatic when both
people have beliefs and then you have
they come
head-to-head i'll eat 50 bucks you keep
you keep it you pee
you keep it
[Music]
there's been a history of america cinema
which is denigrated the fame belittled
dehumanized
is documented the clan used birth of a
nation to lynch
black folks as a filmmaker you know it's
not something to play with
it's going to take many decades to
retell these stories and
i knew that one way that i could do
something about this
was to make films for a diverse audience
to show black people in all our glory
faults warts and whatnot
just grab the camera and go fight to get
your vision
on the screen short of killing somebody
robbing i mean you're going to do what
you have to do get this thing
made majority of people on this earth go
to the grave haven't worked their job to
hate it their whole life
so if you're able to make a living doing
what you love
you won i'm spike lee
and this is my master class
you